je traite attaque lâche aujourd'hui et
thierry ardisson 37 ans homme de presse
de publicité de télé romancier thierry
ardisson qui chatte où il vient d'écrire
un livre dans lequel il sens de
réveiller les instincts monarchique des
français objectif que la population des
descendants du glk appelait servent de
nouveau à quelque chose m le fruit du
sexe sacré à la tête de la france
ce fruit l'a dit il est fait pour ça à
bas les pseudo hommes politiques
dictature médiatique et vive le roi tu
soutiens dans son livre la monarchie
alors pourquoi vaste coup publicitaire
où tu veux épouser une princesse ceni un
coup publicitaire ni le désir d'imposer
une princesse il est certain que mes
adversaires préférerait que je ne sache
pas m'exprimer je sache mal m'exprimer
et il est certain que le fait d'être
publicitaire m'a appris à communiquer et
que quand j'ai décidé de communiquer
l'idée monarchique en france aujourd'hui
c'est plus facile quand on est
publicitaire parce qu'on a le sens de la
de la conviction
pour toi tous les rois sont bons ils on
y re envers le pape ainsi quand même
très souvent dans les bilans je crois
suis dans mon idée est de niveau il ya
d'abord ce que je disais à l'instant
c'est à dire un reportage sur les
derniers rois de france et c'est pas
toujours à biographique ses juges les
montres avec leurs grandeurs et leurs
faiblesses
la première dimension c'est ça la
deuxième dimension c'est de poser la
question la monarchie est elle une
solution moderne de gouvernement en
fixant des cris quand même comme un
homme qui donnait aux pauvres et à ce
que je sache
prenons une reine actuellement la reine
d'angleterre elle préfère monter à
cheval que de donner aux pauvres alors
un roi n'est pas forcément généreux non
au roi n'est pas forcément généreux je
dis pas d'ailleurs que tout me tous les
rois dont je parle dans mon livre je
vais m'en mêle pas très généreux presque
dix ans ils ont bonne presse parce que
si tu veux ils ont tellement eu mauvaise
presse dans les bouquins les autres que
peut-être que j'exagère un peu dans ce
sens là ben henry 5 a épousé un laideron
beau sexe est verrouillée de l'intérieur
la plupart des rois choisissent en
général très mal leurs femmes ya de quoi
flipper sur les descendances non bah oui
là ça a été ça a été dramatique c'est à
dire qu'henry s'est inquiété comme comme
henri iv un chauffeur nous étions tous
là bas il a eu une femme qui était
effectivement qu'ils étaient incapables
d'avoir des enfants
et c'est ainsi que la branche disons
descendante du premier petit fils de
louis xiv du duc de bourgogne
cette branche là s'est éteinte en date
hiriart dix ans de faire une campagne
publicitaire pour le roi il accepterait
enfin une campagne publicitaire pour le
roi je crois d'abord il faut pas qu'ils
aient de parti royaliste si tu veux un
parti royaliste pour moi c'est là mais
paul roy comme un parti anarchiste c'est
un peu ridicule alors une campagne pour
le roi ça supposerait que le roi se
présente à une élection quelconque
je crois que c'est là où est la
difficulté reste forcément admettons que
tu fasses une campagne publicitaire pour
le roi or élections justement je ferai
ça je le ferais tu bernard ali gendre
pourquoi parce que tu utiliseras le même
principe que les hommes politiques
oui mais regarde mon livre par exemple
c'est pas de la pub mais en face de la
communication déjà essayé d'expliquer
des choses assez de la monnaie unique
est ce que les gens disent alliant l'art
à la communication une campagne
publicitaire
oui mais je pense qu'il vaut mieux faire
des livres sur le roi que faire de la
pub alors je te répondrais je crois que
la bonne réponse c'est ça je crois que
les livres parce que c'est un sujet qui
peut pas se traiter comme ça rend 3 m
dont 4 yards y sont ne ferai pas la
campagne publicitaire pour l'euro à la
réflexion peut-être pas au livre est
très logique mais on dit souvent que les
fous sont logiques alors qu'est-ce que
tu réponds bah je réponds que c'est vrai
c'est il ya tous les fous en d'une
logique personnelle son est il fou je
suis fou du roi